[Musique]
aujourd'hui à tam tam jusqu'où iriez
vous pour vos enfants d'emblée on
répondrait jusqu'au bout du mans ou plus
loin encore au coeur de trois premiers
besoins de base se nourrir se loger se
reproduire nous enfants du moins pour
les parents normalement constitués sont
beaucoup nous raison vivre jusqu'au bout
du monde et plus loin encore
[Musique]
bonjour ici vraiment des marteaux l'idée
venue en fait le thème de cette émission
lui venu samedi dernier jeu à la télé je
regrette une vision la diffusion d'un
reportage d'une tendresse infinie doublé
d'un enjeu sociétal profond banca de la
série télé mille et une vies à radio
canada qui est notre diffuseur national
le reportage en question s'intitule je
veux savoir il a été réalisé par notre
collègue journaliste émilie dubreuil une
histoire poignante d'un couple un couple
qui décide de quitter communauté rompre
carrément avec famille amis tradition
tout ce qu'on connaît pour les quatre
enfants du couple pour qu'il puisse
accéder à une éducation séculière
d'année voici un extrait cdi rona yoran
qui écrit à ses parents
online chers parents je sais que mon
départ de la communauté a plongé nos
familles dans le déshonneur
je sais que vous êtes triste réservé aux
deux mois de nous je vous sachiez que je
n'ai jamais pris notre départ à la
légère mais je n'avais pas le choix
comme maire je devais m'assurer que mes
enfants puissent aller dans une école
qui leur permettrait d'avoir un jour un
métier
je voulais surtout qu'ils puissent
réaliser leur rêve réalisé leur rêve
mais ils grouillent bonjour où l'enjeu
qu'elles cachent des tendresses disait
et à enjeu sociétal ou cynique c'est un
personnage d'une grande tendresse
monsieur que vous avez qui est au coeur
de votre reportage we were est un
amoureux seraient au sens très large
c'est à dire qu'il y aura nan faut le
présenter vient d'une communauté
hassidique tôt juive hassidique
ce sont les juifs qui pratiquent le
judaïsme de façon très très rigoureuse
et dans leur communauté dans leur
culture ils résistent en fait à
l'acculturation à l'assimilation
culturelle est une façon de résister à
l'assimilation culturelle pour préserver
leur rapport à la religiosité c'est de
scolariser leurs enfants notamment les
garçons dans un système d'éducation
fermé sur le monde c'est à dire qu'ils
forment des enfants qui vont pouvoir
réussir au sein même de leur communauté
n'est pas à l'extérieur de celle là donc
ils vont utiliser les textes sacrés vont
posséder très bien l'araméen par exemple
qui la langue de g
l'hébreu classique mais pas l'hébreu
contemporain et le yiddish et donc ces
enfants là vivent en retrait de la
société en général de la majorité et il
y aura nan qui se perd lé kim que mon
âge que 40 ans aujourd'hui a grandi dans
ce système là qui forment des théologies
quand même des gens qui sont très très
qui ont beaucoup étudié qui ont un
esprit critique et c'est le paradoxe lui
regarder ça et avait soif de
connaissance et se disent qu'il manque
quelque chose dans ce système
d'éducation qui va qu complètement les
connaissances non religieuse du parcours
éducatif dont qui sédimentent quelque
chose il est extrêmement frustré de sa
est tranquillement il entre pie de
convaincre sa femme qui elle est et
chantre dans la communauté donc écrivait
des chansons à la gloire de dieu qui
étaient des succès mondiaux parce qu'il
faut savoir que ces communautés est
écrit c'est un peu comme des
multinationales 16 occasions un siège
social quelque part dans le monde le
plus souvent à new york ou à jérusalem
est après ça ils ont des succursales un
peu partout et donc elle était très très
fervente et ça a pris des années à moins
qu'il a comme minc et qu elle aussi se
rendre compte qu'il y avait une sorte de
lavage de cerveau d'une certaine façon
et à quel point les enfants souffraient
de ne pas avoir accès à des
connaissances et à quel point finalement
bris mais leur liberté de choisir a in
fine au parce que ils n'ont pas les
connaissances quand il gratte une ses
collègues n'ont pas les connaissances
ils veulent sortir de là pour exercer un
métier c'est même pas un choix religieux
à la limite c'est à dire qu'ils peuvent
pas si quelqu un rêve d'être psychiatre
par exemple c'est impossible
j'ai demandé à deux collègues de
participer à cette émission leonardo
crime unodc i qui est notre web match
qui travaillent
en trois langues lui en espagnol en
anglais en français et qui est partie
d'argentine avec famille et où il disait
aussi en sous titre pour mes enfants
les robes rouges c'était la même chose
bourbon autre monde c'était la même
chose on la laissait tout de l'autre
côté quand elle a quitté on est on est
on a pensé en fait la famille la culture
et tout non non aux sentiments ils ont
resté de l'autre côté je pense que
l'imitation c'est comme ça dans les
clubs et ces jeunes là je pense qu'ils
auraient immigrés à l'intérieur de la
société canadienne alors parce qu'ils
étaient dédain mais finalement ils ont
dû sortir vite en mai à l'extérieur mais
mon titre de travail longtemps pour ce
documentaire
c'était immigrés de l'intérieur parce
que la femme du couple qui s'appelle
chiffre a donc ils viennent à 30 km de
boisbriand qui situe à 30 km de moyens
elle s'est inscrite dans un centre pour
immigrants dans côte-des-neiges avec
déjà qu'ils venaient de français et se
sont littéralement des mineurs et je
dirais même que c'est presque plus
difficile plus ardue que des gens qui
migrent par exemple du pakistan de
l'argentine parce qu'il n'y a pas de
réseau à quelqu'un qui arrive du
pakistan il va avoir la mine un cousin
de l'ong de la fesse droite qui va voir
des gens pour l'aider alors que ces gens
si ce beau souci un ostracisme chauny
dont l'anglais aussi quoique personne on
ne parle pas de la part je suis demande
à mon collègue levante secondes ce qui
est de la section anglaise et les ventes
qui est notre polyglotte ici
en français c'est quoi ces sixièmes
parlons d'abord ya l'arménien qui le
rend d'origine le recy étudier l'arabe
il étudié la loi d'université il ya
publié en anglais ici puis travail en
anglais puis il peut faire de la région
français si ça c'est pas un polyglotte
j'en connais pas
soucy un départ de morzine evans l'urss
de l'époque quand je partis à chute du
mur de berlin c'était c'était beaucoup
moins une chape de plomb que vous
pensiez que c'était vous un accident
mais il a fallu que je parte mais moi
j'ai des raisons personnelles et travail
j'ai que je commençais travaille comme
journaliste à la fin de le prêt de
l'effondrement de l'union soviétique à
9,92 danser ou la saison 90
ma carrière journalistique n'a pas duré
très long avant que j'ai commencé à
recevoir de menace et ma femme était
enceinte à ce moment et c'est devenu
tellement sérieux que après avoir des
gens qui ont tiré sur nous on a décidé
qu'il fallait
bon ça ce serait pareil vous font pas
mais c'est aussi c'est un choix on
savait que c'est pour un enfant ça
serait mieux avec moi j'ai rêvé de
retourner je laisse un travail
incroyablement intéressant les premières
années d'indépendance d'arménie c'était
incroyable tu voyais rien ne dit pas oui
oui mais moi je voyage un peu partout
dans l'ex union soviétique j'ai commencé
ma carrière en couvrir la guerre de
deux hôtes karabagh unis la guerre
civile a ajouté jiji
oui la guerre en ossétie je fais la
guerre civile au tadjikistan alors j'ai
réussi de voyager un peu mais ici je
parlais français quand je suis venu ici
mais pas dans l'est je ne sais pas
comment j'ai réussi mais mon anglais à
commencer de zéro j'ai réussi de
développer tellement vite que
à 88 j'ai commencé à travailler à la
gazette notamment s
mais le thème pour human and et son
épouse chiffre à et pour les quatre
enfants pourront enfin pour vos seins
fins et ses thèmes la c7 ce départ ce
déracinement pour la prochaine
génération
ça veut dire quoi pour soi écoutez nous
on parle toujours avec avec ma conjointe
la possibilité de revenir
bonjour jean sénac mais si on les pense
comme ceux on dit non non on va retenir
qu'un des avants y vont avoir ses
propres chemins et parce que là
maintenant six ans avant si on répond
dans l'argentine les racines ça va être
l'heure si ça met ça face aux menées ici
ses amis sont ici sa vie est ici par
français intrus par l'anglais à
l'extérieur quand il joue avec ses amis
ont essayé de maintenir l'espagnol à la
maison parce que moi c'est nous avoir
troisième langue
un plus l'espagnol mais quand même je
pense que ça s'est vraiment l'impact
très facile ça vaut maintenant avec
massa font partie les pas mais là il me
dit dans le reportage
mais vous êtes amené à boisbriand
avec erwan et il ya une confrontation
avec un religieux qui disait moment
donné par exemple est ce que toi est ce
que tu es malheureux ici toi est ce que
tu es maintenant passer ce point tant
comme ça tous les hommes ont dit nous on
est très bien le très heureux dans ce
qu'on fait envoyons un système
d'éducation qui existe depuis 5000 ans
pourquoi son show fait lequel vos fait
ses preuves on changera ensuite cela dit
en israël on vous a dit aussi si rien ne
change dans 50 ans l'état est en
faillite
ouais c'est ça alors je vous expliquais
que les communautés à ce texte un peu
comme des multinationales évidemment le
plus grand nombre de ces gros pacifique
parce qu'il y en a plusieurs c'est pas
un truc monolithique et plusieurs
groupes avec leurs propres écoles
différents nous on voit pas trop la
distinction mais quand on connaît un peu
plus oui il y a
mais ce qui les rassemble c'est vraiment
cette manière d'éduquer particulièrement
les garçons et donc de façon très simple
si quelqu'un veut dans une école où il
apprend exhaustivement les textes sacrés
ça ne fait pas de lui quelqu'un de très
rentable pour le produit intérieur brut
donc ça va pas d'années déjà j'ai dû 250
kw mais si ce que les économistes en
israël en calcul est à dire que ces
hommes là qui sont formés à l'eal études
religieuses ne devienne ne deviennent
pas des professionnels ou très peu de
winne des des gens d'affaires
donc ne peut être ne peut pas beaucoup
de taxes ni d'impôt mêmes doivent
recevoir des subsides de lutter pour
pouvoir y arriver parce qu'ils ont
plusieurs enfants new york où free
mobile très beau comme ils sont
extrêmement religieux ils font
énormément d'enfants et donc leur toute
croissance démographique est très très
impressionnant ce moment ils sont 10% la
population en israël
dans ce moment un enfant sur cinq de
moins de 6 ans appartient ces groupes
religieux souvient pour ce salon est
donc rendu à 20% et en calcul qui vont
donc que ça augmente de façon
exponentielle et donc d'ici 2030 2040 on
calcule que israël ne sera plus en
mesure d'arriver à l'ail est une urgence
nationale de mettre ces gens là au
travail et donc de compenser leur
déficit d'éducation pratico pratique
à l'école parce que c'est un problème
rationnelle c'est un calcul rationnel
qu'on fait
arsène un exemple typique du reportage
de cette facture de connaissances
écoutez bien ça
pony mendes
un mois
photo mec
tina
match non
[Musique]
bahman
bagdad - trois brillants aliot
à nîmes évoqué mieux mais même ça
devrait voir ça vous jette par terre le
vent nouveau coup venu quand j'ai
regardé ça je m'en venais passer comme
en commun tu peux incroyable jouer je
restais samo c'est incroyable qu'on peut
avoir des images des chutes niagara
quand on est quelque part au
nagorno-karabakh oui soit mais à 50 km
du fleuve saint-laurent paul connaître
c'est tout tu connais pas la différence
entre fleuve a fait il ya dix ans comme
ddm hm profonde sympathie que les cours
de géographie ce même des connaissances
quotidien qu'on apprend juste en sortant
de notre maison c'est ce qu'ont ils sont
tellement enfermés dans leur communauté
que même des connaissances pratiques
qu'on est qui n'a pas besoin de deux
cours de géographie pour comprendre
c'est quoi une rivière ou l'aneth parce
que vous savez vous mais non c'est vrai
qu'un jeu mais quand on a tourné cette
scène là qui fait vraiment tous les
jeunes qui chaque beaucoup beaucoup de
gens ou donc les personnes à genève le
fleuve saint-laurent ce carmen iconique
au québec
tout le monde sait combien cela mais ce
qu'on voit pas et malheureusement
j'avais dit veulent que je fasse des
choix montage c'est qu'on ne passe à
journée note haut et on est allé voir
plein de trucs le mont royal par exemple
qui quand même incontournable canton
aucune des moyens michael jackson jamie
un cd de michael jackson dans le taux
jamais entendu tulle de sa gamme hommage
à michael jackson a marqué la génération
la planète au complet j'ai compris que
ça quelqu'un dans un bidonville en
intéressés qui michael jackson mais ça
prouve à quel point ça fonctionne
cette sorte de forteresse intellectuelle
qui s'explique par l'histoire du jeu
facile